buonasera a tutti vorrei raccontarvi
proprio di un modo di esprimersi
universale che però non è una lingua
proprio perché tutte le persone di tutto
il mondo se la guardano la possono
capire il nome visual vernacular il
visual vernacular è proprio una tecnica
d'arte visiva di espressione visiva
collegata al gruppo della comunità dei
sordi però che può fare questa forma
d'arte non tutti i sordi la conoscono
tutti i soldi la capiscono ma è proprio
una vena artistica che si esprime il
feature vernacular il nome del visual
vernacular è stato dato da un americano
bernard bug ma il visual vernacular che
cos'è e da dove nasce la nascita si
perde proprio nella notte dei tempi era
proprio un modo di raccontare di passare
il tempo proprio degli istituti per
sordi delle famiglie oppure tra gli
amici che si raccontavano delle cose ma
già da tempo immemore quindi proprio che
cos'è è un tipo di espressione che viene
fuori
adesso io vorrei darvi degli esempi
allora vedete
queste sono chiavi nella lingua dei
segni chiavi sono tutte diverse però se
ci fate caso per esempio può essere la
chiave di casa oppure invece la chiave
della macchina questi segni ma nel vice
al vernacular provo a darvi un esempio
però attenzione ricordatevi non fate
confusione perché non è una lingua dei
segni
proprio perché tutto il mondo nel mondo
ci sono diverse lingue dei segni
la lingua dei segni italiana quella
americana quella francese e loro sono
proprio uguali alle lingue parlate
all'inglese al francese l'italiano
perché proprio ognuna ha delle regole di
grammatica delle strutture per esempio
se io vedo un'altra lingua dei segni
non è che perché parlo la lista la
conosco non capisco niente se non
conosco le regole di grammatica invece
nel visual vernacular proprio perché è
una forma di espressione artistica
visiva io posso capirla sostanzialmente
che cosa fa racconta quindi posso
provare a farvi degli esempi ok proviamo
a fare degli esempi per allargare
ramente vediamo adesso io vi do facciamo
piccolo racconto e se andiamo a vederlo
dentro di visual vernacular troviamo dei
punti in comune possiamo fare un'analisi
quali sono questi punti in comune
adesso li vediamo insieme l'espressione
facciale
questo implica che io vidi ha il
significato e l'emozione di che cosa
stiamo facendo
lo zoom lo zoom da proprio un effetto
ravvicinato ho allontanato dell'immagine
dell'oggetto che sta rappresentando il
3d questo significa che io possa
rappresentare un oggetto da più
angolazioni posizioni diverse nello
spazio
la spazializzazione quindi significa
chiaramente che io posso mettere nello
spazio delle cose per esempio un albero
e il mare che si infrange contro di esso
ok e sono entrambi nello spazio segni in
parallelo cosa significa per esempio
possa avere un personaggio una donna ok
che ha una sua storia e un'altra donna
un'altra però possono stare insieme
nello stesso spazio e le possiamo
rappresentare entrambe metafore visive
che cosa significa che io uso dei modi
per raccontarvi il messaggio facendoli
degli esempi visivi collegati proprio al
racconto il ritmo il ritmo importante
perché può essere veloce può essere
lento può essere lentissimo dipende e
serve anche la pantomima volte
ok quindi per capire meglio e poi lim
persona mento cosa significa che io
divento l'oggetto l'animale o proprio la
foto ok quello prende vita io entro in
quello ok quindi in pratica il vice
ilver natola che cosa fa può prendere
degli oggetti degli animali degli
ambienti delle foto ok dei luoghi e dei
disegni e trasformarli proprio in un
racconto proprio come se fossero un film
ok allora vi faccio vedere siete pronti
il girasole